there that's 8th grade the movie there's
a little bit okay so because I know
you've all been waiting for it this is
my review of a crate so I I know a lot
now uh people been asking for this
review but there's a few interesting
reasons why I thought well first of all
I apologize because this is one I did
have a screener for like I could have
saw I could have seen it early but uh
there's two reasons why not well one is
that I I think I was working that day or
something like that but then the other
thing was you know I saw the trailer for
this movie and I said you know this
looks good it kind of looks like I feel
like I know what this movie's gonna be
though and we'll kind of get to that in
a bit
it's one of the reasons why I'm doing
this review so this is very much truth
in advertising uh this is definitely a
movie about eighth grade or rather the
last week of eighth grade I should say
but but it's very much that that age of
being around eighth grade and a lot of
people's enjoyment of this movie is
going to come from how they enjoyed
eighth grade and my guess is there's uh
there's three people they're gonna have
a certain there's three main responses
that I think three people three
responses that this film is going to get
what its gonna be people that see it is
just it was the point of that nothing
happened screw it which I get
there's not many twists and turns or
anything like that in the movie by I
mean watching the trailer I think you
could figure out that that's not the
kind of movie it is there's others
that's gonna see it for kind of the
awkward strange confused but very
important time in you know a child's
life that will very much impact them as
they become adults very much about
closing one door and opening another and
they will say man this really connects
with me like this is so honest so
truthful and this just really really
holds a deep place in my heart and then
there's the third kind
which a lot of people have told me they
don't want to see this movie for this
very same reason which is that they've
gone through eighth grade and it wasn't
fun that age is an awkward age and it's
uncomfortable and it's not something
that a lot of people want to relive I'm
kind of one of those people and that's
the reason I kind of wasn't interested
in seeing this movie because I said I'm
sure this is done well but I don't look
it's specifically that Graem that's like
the exact grade I really don't like
because we moved around a lot when I was
a kid because my dad was in the Navy and
so like he kind of it kind depended
where we were if I fit in well or I
didn't fit in well if I was popular I
was not popular and 8th grade was just
like just when we moved to a new place
it from a place that we've loved and we
moved to a new place that we did love
and we just have we were all kind of
miserable there we just we did not fit
in or at least I didn't fit in to the
new school I was given to so given to
but then when high school started and
you know things got better I got to know
people better and stuff like that but
eighth grade was not a happy time for me
and this is a movie that is not it's not
like a miserable movie or anything it's
not like welcome to the dollhouse but it
is a movie that definitely very well
taps into the insecurities of that age
and if I'm guessing correctly again I'm
not an eighth grader but it seems like
it's connecting it very well to like
today's technology to the way kids talk
now which I don't think it's too
different from you know like when I was
growing up but the but definitely the
technological angle and the social media
and and the putting videos online and
stuff like that and finding kind of
different outlets for what you're going
through
so I knew a lot of people I have a lot
of friends they were saying like well I
don't want to see that movie cuz I hated
eighth grade I've knowed a lot of people
that that said that so and they weren't
interested but I had this one
friend who was telling me over and over
you gotta see this movie and on top of
that Rotten Tomatoes was just praising
the hell out of him even had this thing
this is why you should ignore the are
rating on eighth grade and I know if
they're talking about I mean it's like
it's it's are for a good reason I mean
don't get me wrong but I mean it's like
I can't remember they say that many
swear words and there's a see if they do
talk about like sexual stuff you know
easy freighters talking about sexual
stuff I think there's even a scene where
like a woman's holding like a dildo or
something like that you're like yeah if
an instruction no so so this is very
much this is very much kind of letting
people out there who aren't abating
whether or not to see this movie like
trying to help them figure out what kind
of movie this is you know is this
something they would like if some people
say it's very depressing other people
will say is very inspiring a lot of
people say it's both and my opinion is
both but it's it's kind of exactly what
I thought it was gonna be so if you're
looking at this trailer and you're
saying man that looks like a lot of
uncomfortable awkwardness you know and
sort of like kids that you know are
trying to figure things out but talk
like they had things figure down they're
gonna embarrass themselves but it's also
part of growing up and they're not gonna
be liked by a lot of other kids or
they're gonna be ignored but then
they're also gonna be liked by a couple
other kids and they have a sweet moment
with like you know me the parents and
stuff it's that kind of movie but it's
not done like I don't know like American
Beauty or something where there's like
clearly a three-act structure where this
thing that happened the beginning is
gonna happen at the end there's a lot of
things that technically don't go
anywhere there's a lot of stuff where
like she'll meet a new character and
have a very unique scene with that
character and then just you never see
that character again there's kind of
stuff like that and and it's good that's
like that cuz a lot of a lot of film is
very much building up this very current
you know time and place and personality
and who you are there's even like a
weird thing where she like puts away a
memory box like from sixth grade and
they opened in eighth grade it's like
what is that something that
like only two years but but that's
something a lot of it is you know sort
of like it's taking these steps and
Serve going into you know the next step
you know it's it because you're going
through tough stuff doesn't mean you
give up on it there's a lot of good
things and yes a lot of it I related to
you know I think because we have moved
around a lot there's a lot of times
where you know I I was kind of
everything I was the popular kid I was
the total loser
I you know ashamed to say I made fun of
kids but I was also made fun of at you
know some points it's one of those
things where it's like depending on
where I was and how well I fit in you
know that they were different
experiences but that's also part of
growing up so I think it's also one of
those things where if you look at this I
like let's say you say it's greats the
best time of your life let's just say
you were the school jock you know we're
a sports team and you did awesome
everybody loved you and stuff you still
gotta have something awkward like
everybody goes through something awkward
I think everybody can find something in
this that they can relate to in terms of
like that confusion or even if you were
super successful you know at that age
you may think I got everything figured
out and and of course you don't but but
a lot of people have a age you know I
think they do have a lot of stuff
figured out or more things than they're
aware of and this movie very cleverly
ties that in with her kind of video v
logs that maybe two or three people
watch I mean nobody even watches them
but she puts him out there to kind of
figure her own stuff out very clearly
and one of the things I like most is
that the editing in this is very good is
if she's invite to this party that this
girl has ever already made very clear
does not want her at the party is only
inviting her because I think I think
it's her mother because she's like
what's your name again it's kind of
weird but um but but she forces her to
invited to this party and she does a
v-log saying like you know I I was
having this party and my dad want me to
invite this friend and I didn't want to
but I did anyway and you know when I
met up with her though I found out she
was actually really nice and really kind
and I'm glad that you know he made me
invite that person over so she's clearly
changing things too
you know almost play it out how she
wants it to happen in her mind and
they're playing this video while she's
walking up to the door of the party
which is very clever because again it
really taps into kind of what the
mindset is at that age where you're kind
of playing in what will happen what you
want to happen you know hopefully making
it what you think will happen and you
know if that's kind of what's going
through your mind and me very much taps
into like you know this person that has
kind of social anxiety and she's not I
like it because the the kid does not
seem like your stereotypical geek you
know in a lot of these movies like the
geeks are making fun of super super all
the time and it's just really you know
just constant and this kid just seems
like a normal shy kid who wants an
identity and she's still trying to
figure out her identity and the videos
are kind of her hobby in figuring it out
but it's also not like it's clearly a
journal even though the videos are set
up to like give advice and I also like
that there's kind of little victories in
this like her going up and singing
karaoke at the party which you never
hear her sing which again is very clever
uh is a victory to her to a point where
it doesn't matter how she sounds and
nobody boos nobody rolls their eyes and
obey or anything like that she sings and
that's it and a lot of the time the
movie the reactions of the other
characters it's not as much about that
as much as her reaction how she feels
about it there's this scene near the end
where she finally tells off I guess not
really a bully but she very much you
know let somebody know how she feels
about something she does the whole thing
without looking up at them I mean I get
very clever and we don't see how the
kids really react we see a little bit
while she's talking but when she walks
away she just gets this little smile and
it's like it's it's not
she told the person off in a really
great way it was super odd and awkward
and uncomfortable but she was proud of
it so it's it very much sort of hits
those little victories and I will say it
does not end on again kind of like
welcome to the dollhouse a park Imperial
a lot so that it doesn't really end on a
note like that you know when I operate
it back to that again when I first saw
welcome to the dollhouse which s where
this is now review of uh I didn't really
get I didn't see the point of it I'm
like okay we're just seeing a person get
made fun of for a couple hours why is
that interesting why is that fun or
anything and when I got a little older I
appreciate it a little bit more but it's
still not really my thing I have an
appreciation for it but I don't really
like it
but I get why other people enjoy it and
I do get the comedy of it too and I
admire the harshness of it but with this
film I feel like it's it's not quite
doing that it's just combining enough a
new stuff with having this kid can be
someone that can disappear but it's not
like you know what the hell's that drew
Barrymore comedy was it never been
kissed or whatever where it's like in
high school I just disappeared and
nobody noticed me yet nobody noticed
Drew Barrymore weird no it's not like
you know just kind of a typical teen
comedy I mean it's done with a lot of
heart and a lot of thought and watching
this even though hobbies I grew up a boy
I'm watching this I'm saying okay well I
recognize that feeling I recognize that
moment I recognize but something like
that happened but I also recognize the
nice moments too so very much the reason
I want to do this review is anyone
that's like if you see this movie and
your thing it's either gonna be all a
downer or it's gonna be super sappy
about and uplifting and stuff uh it's
something kind of in-between and
ultimately ends on a positive note but
it is I'll even say half and half I'll
say 70% of doubt
or 70% a anxious uncomfortable awkward
you know that's probably better way of
putting it
because I mean there there's a lot of
movies about childhood are much more
aggressive and this is not an aggressive
movie this is very much focusing on sort
of the awkward stuff that can happen and
how it can impact a person without
necessarily having to spell it out to
you it can just sort of show what
they're going through when she goes to
this party for example you know she she
has this one-piece suit and nobody else
there is wearing a one-piece and it's
something where it's like she never says
that she never mentions it but but you
notice it it's like oh well like all the
other girls are wearing like bikinis and
stuff like that and she you know does
not have you know the body's like what
they have in stuff is a clearly a
different friend group but then like
when they're taking the picture you know
taking the picture of all the girls
together and they're all game together
and they say oh we can't see you you
know main character we can't see you
come to the front and you're thinking
like well Kay they're gonna do the thing
where everyone rolls their eyes or they
push her off and they play some sort of
mean trick and then she turns into Kari
and zaps everybody no but you know what
I mean like does some sir a mean trick
and they don't I mean they just let her
be a part of the picture
okay whatever they they don't really
like her but you know it's they're
trying to be more realistic like that's
what people would do they just love
being the picture and be like whatever
you know and that's kind of the feel
it's like most of it feels very legit
very realistic there's one or two
moments where they don't sometimes the
father does something like after he
drops her off in them all he does
something that I thought was very odd
and kind of out of character even for
him you know there there's another weird
scene where like this this boy is
driving this girl home and I mean you
can see it's coming a mile away but he
obviously tries to hit on her and tries
to get with her and the way he does it
even for eighth grade actually think
it's 8th grade I think it's like ninth
grade this kid is very odd and I don't
know that felt very like the way was
done when it was very very strange but
you know it didn't seem like yeah that's
that age like now that's just weird um
but you know once in a while they'll do
a shtick that's like oh it's that stick
way like I've seen this in a comedy but
it feels mostly pretty genuine and when
somebody actually does want to hang out
with her or she actually does get a
friend that's really cool and she's
super anxious and she practices how to
say hello and stuff you feel good that
she actually like is connecting with
someone and then you feel just as bad
when you know something really
uncomfortable happens and again a lot of
it is kind of done through the
performance and done through you know
just the various ways that they show
what this person is going through you
know visually so yeah I guess what I'm
trying to get across is that this is a
very genuine movie it feels very much
like eighth grade and even if you were
super popular in eighth grade like
everyone can find something in this
movie they can be like yeah I went
through that yeah that's something I can
relate to but that doesn't necessarily
mean you'll get into the movie you
either say you want more twists and
turns or a more traditional story or
you'll say that this is a little too
real and I just that's not something I'm
interested in seeing for me I'm glad I
saw it uh I don't know if I'd see it
again for all the people that were
saying like yes this just a movie that
shows the genuine awkwardness of eighth
grade yeah this and it does it well but
it isn't 100% downer it does bring up
some positive things as and you know
genuine joyous stuff but like I said
it's 70% awkward uncomfortable you know
stuff that maybe you'll really connect
with um I think it's no reason really
one to talk about because it is a movie
where I feel like there'll be a lot of
people there just like this is not the
movie for me and I I would kind of be in
that category I just be like I remember
eighth grade fine hey you know I don't
need I'm not someone that likes to go
back and watch all home movies of myself
or anything like that I don't like
remembering how awkward
I was and I acknowledge it I know I was
but it's one of those things where I'm
just like I don't like reliving it um
but a movie like this very much can sort
of take that feeling it can say it's
okay to you know everyone went through
this you know everyone went through sort
of these different stages of awkwardness
at that age you know that's really that
age and for some people maybe they
forgot about it and this kind of brings
it back and it's very much about moving
forward and you know again there are
some clever things even though I don't
know why it was two years that that time
capsule memory box or whatever you know
it's very much about that happen now you
know moving forward to the next step and
they they do that in a very clever way
so this movie is a shot very clever it's
edited very clever that the sound design
as well with where they put the audio of
like her videos explaining stuff and
what she says and why and and so forth
is really good when she's upset when
they have it go quiet you know maybe you
have her talk or just certain songs or
whatever I mean it's stuff that you
definitely recognize and I'm glad it
doesn't take place in the 80s or the 90s
I mean don't get me wrong I when
something like that comes out it's like
cool that's when I grew up but it's
really everywhere right now and I think
if you're gonna do something with that
it's fine people want to do something
with that but they really have to have
more to it you know just a coming-of-age
story in the blank decade it is getting
a little old like you really really have
to put a different spin on it which I
think people can do and are doing but
we're seeing a lot of kind of just ooh
references the 80s the 90s or whatever
so I'm hoping that people kind of wake
up more that there has to be more to it
than that and there is a lot to this and
like I said the fact that it's set now
and it does address technology and sort
of the different hobbies that people
have I mean people are on there they're
on their phones a lot you know in this
and they're on their laptops and
everything you know I
feel like it's there's gonna be a large
peep a large amount of people that
really do connect with this movie and so
I kind of wanna make that clear to that
is this is a very very good movie it's a
very very well-done movie and if you're
looking at this and you say I really
want to relive what eighth grade is like
or experience what eighth grade was like
this gets several elements even it's not
exactly your childhood it gets several
strong elements of it but there are
going to be people that just don't have
an interest in that I'm a me for me the
stuff I like to I know what's ironic the
guy that plays in this now a critic but
the stuff I like to relive is you know
things like movies and shows maybe see a
toy I grew up with or something like
that or a place or an environment I like
seeing that because that sort of brings
back a lot of emotions and a lot of
feelings that I connected to those
certain objects when they actually bring
up the actual emotions and and topics
and stuff like that you know that's
where I'm like because it's I don't know
it's just strange as some people have
different things they connect to you
know when they bring up like the exact
emotions I like talking about those
emotions I don't always like reliving
them I like reliving them through you
know objects and movies and you know
places and things like that you know
that stuff is fun but like if you were
to show me like a video of me watching
that movie being in that place or
whatever I wouldn't want to see that you
know it's a I don't know man maybe it's
too rose-colored or whatever maybe it's
just yeah I don't always like looking
back at how awkward I am even though I
acknowledge I'm awkward back then and
everything but it's everyone's gonna
have like a different reaction to it and
I've known a lot of people that have
said they don't want to see this movie
because of that they're like I'm sure
it's great I'm sure it gets down eighth
grade I just have no interest in sitting
a very accurate portrayal of eighth
grade so um yeah it's I hope it's a very
strange thing to kind of say but you
know like go see this movie even though
didn't really want to see it and you
know I'm glad I saw it I guess but I
really feel like there's gonna be a lot
of people that do connect with this film
um ironically probably not eighth
graders I currently although you never
know it's something where I feel like
they would see it and I'd be like okay
cool I mean but it's it's that age like
you don't want to admit you're going
through a lot of that stuff you know but
some people do and Ken and it's I don't
know it's an interesting movie it does
deserve to be talked about it does
deserve to be celebrated because it is
very very well done it very well
captures you know that that that time in
life for a lot of people but if Fame was
watching the trailer thinking I don't
know I just don't want to relive that
you do relive it it's also the positive
with the negative but it's it's a fair
amount of negative to jazz it's just not
welcome to the dollhouse make um so yeah
I like I said that this was a movie I
really just saw because a friend of mine
was really recommending it and Rotten
Tomatoes was was really praising
praising the hell out of it and it
deserves it and I really think it's
worth saying you know if this is a very
good special movie I think a lot of
people are gonna have a strong
connection to it it's just that me but
even I I acknowledge that there are a
lot of people who will do and should
have a very very strong connection with
this and if you're looking at the
trailer thinking yeah but maybe I want
to see that maybe this this will be
something deep and meaningful it it
probably will but yet don't expect
twists and turns don't expect anything
super positive or super negative
honestly um you know it is exactly what
advertises it is eighth grade so take
that for what it's worth that's about it
and I will see you next time take care
you